this is the park just five minutes from
his home where George walks with purpose
I'm a suicide attempt Survivor
um I attempted suicide both at 14 years
old and at 23. I felt shame and an
embarrassment and
for someone to try and end their own
life and feel that way is just we can't
we can't have that in our society we're
here to talk about how we can all do
more George is backing a new Charter
that would build Suicide Prevention and
support into every UK workplace it's
explaining how to have those safe
conversations how to spot the signs a
lot of people would be quite hesitant as
to having that conversation because for
fear of saying the wrong thing exactly
and that's that's trying that's what
we're trying to eliminate it's not just
about saving human lives I was out of
work for a year and a half and what
effect does that have on the economy
um
on productivity on efficiency
on tax I mean there are so many things
that it affects but this is about
prevention this is making sure that no
one has to get to that point in the
first place and if they do there are the
right processes procedures and people in
place to help them out of that suicide
is the biggest killer of men under the
age of 50. we need to really provide a
supportive and safe place
for someone going through such difficult
thoughts that they can get the help that
they need everyone deserves it everyone
deserves that help
this summer he will be one of hundreds
of people who will carry this the Baton
of Hope through 12 UK cities
stimulating the conversation and
spreading the hope that George now lives
for
Tom Parmenter Sky News Surrey